What happened to Josh Holloway after the whirlwind
success of Lost came to an end?
What does an actor who once struggled to book
guest roles do after the gleam of his big
break wears off?
We've got the whole story for you right here.
Holloway was born in 1969 in San Jose, California,
the second of four brothers.
When he was two, he moved with his family
into a trailer in Georgia's Blue Ridge Mountains.
His acting career got a huge break in 1993
in the form of the Aerosmith music video for
"Cryin,'" when he played a thief who tries
to snatch Alicia Silverstone's purse.
He eventually started grabbing TV guest roles
on shows like Angel and CSI.
His most significant pre-Lost project was
perhaps the 2002 Sci-Fi original movie Sabretooth,
in which he fights to survive the rampage
of a prehistoric cat.
But he was struggling so much that he almost
quit acting to become a realtor in 2004.
Later that year, though, his career really
took off into the stratosphere.
In TV's streaming age, it's hard to convey
just how big a deal Lost was in its heyday.
Averaging over 15 million viewers a week during
its first season, it inspired the sort of
obsessive fan culture that makes even Game
of Thrones viewers blush.
In the modern media era where nerd culture
reigns supreme, it might be difficult to appreciate
how uniquely dedicated Lost's fanbase was.
As loveable rogue James "Sawyer" Ford, Holloway
instantly shot into stardom in a way he probably
never imagined possible.
"You sure know how to make a girl feel special,
Sawyer."
"You're incredible, Sawyer."
One might think becoming a household name
overnight would do wonders for Holloway's
acting career, but that actually wasn't the
case, at least not at first.
During Lost's 2004 to 2010 run, the only outside
projects he worked on were just a few low-budget
films.
It isn't hard to see why this was the case,
as he and his family spent most of the year
in Hawaii while he was shooting the the ABC
series.
Holloway also had to turn down some major
roles because of his grueling shooting schedule,
perhaps most notably the part of Gambit in
the X-Men films.
Even after Lost ended, it seemed as if bad
luck would curse Holloway into becoming a
has-been pretty quickly.
At one point he was considered for the part
of Crossbones in Captain America: The Winter
Soldier, and he even turned down the CBS series
Person of Interest because he didn't want
to move his family across the country.
He would eventually work his way into more
acting opportunities, but it's hard to look
past what could've been if a couple of these
chances had broken in his favor.
"I was thinking about Lost today and how much
I miss it and I’m sure you’re sick of
it with that stuff"
“I’m not because my wife tells me that
often.”
"She does?"
"She does."
After struggling to get a serious film career
off the ground in the immediate years after
Lost, Holloway returned to the small screen
in 2014 as the main character in the CBS series
Intelligence.
The show was a cyber-themed action-adventure
thriller that unfortunately for Holloway only
aired 13 episodes before getting the axe.
He starred as Gabriel, a tech-enhanced man
designed to tackle major threats while working
for U.S. Cyber Command.
With Intelligence, CBS wasn't trying to reinvent
the wheel, and there's something to be said
for easy-to-digest thrillers where the good
guys are Capital-G Good and the bad guys are
shady beyond belief.
Alas, it never lived up to the network's expectations,
nor was it ever given a full chance to find
a real audience.
Holloway eventually found another winning
project in 2016 in the form of Colony, a sci-fi
drama that ran on USA Network for three seasons.
Though it never managed to capture a significantly
large audience, it was a cult hit that was
generally well-regarded by critics.
It even managed to garner three straight Saturn
Award nominations for Best Science Fiction
Television Series.
Colony was set in a dystopian version of Los
Angeles, where residents live under military
occupation by the Transitional Authority,
an organization serving an extraterrestrial
group referred to as the "Hosts."
Holloway starred as a former U.S. Army Ranger
and FBI Special Agent who was trying to save
his missing son.
"How do you live with this job?"
Coming off the heels of Colony, Holloway landed
a role in the upcoming third season of Paramount
Network's Yellowstone.
The show stars Kevin Coster as billionaire
John Dutton, the patriarch of a family that
controls the largest contiguous ranch in the
United States.
The Duttons are under constant attack by those
around them, and show co-creator Taylor Sheridan
wants the show to be a look at a violent world
separated from typical media scrutiny.
Sheridan has said,
"The show is both timely and timeless.
As much as it explores themes painfully relevant
to the world today, it explores the very essence
of family, and how the actions of one member
can alter the course of generations."
Holloway has signed on for a season-long arc
as a charming hedge fund manager with ambitious
plans in Montana.
With a string of regular TV roles over the
last several years, it's safe to say that
the future is now looking bright for Josh
Holloway.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.